High school was bad.
I was obviously gay and some kids didn't like that,...
...and I did get harassed.
What I'd love you to take away from it is that however bad it is now, it gets better...
...and it can get great.
And it's important for adults to reach out to kids, and share our stories,...
...so that they can picture futures for themselves that are worth sticking around for.
Okay, little ones.
Here's the first thing that you need to know.
You are perfect and wonderful exactly as you are.
You're not alone.
There are a ton of us out here in this world.
I love you without even knowing you.
It gets better!
There's art to be made.
There are songs to be sung.
So, hold on.
Look at me.
80 years old. It gets better with age.
Listen to me.
It gets better.
It does get better.
So much better.
You'll be fine, partner.
Your life can be amazing,...
...but you have to tough this period of it out...
...and you have to live.